assalamualaikum warahmatullah better
care to brothers and sisters and dear
friends today's reminder is about the
last 10 nights we need to make sure we
take full opportunity of this brothers
and sisters it's equivalent to 83 years
of worship a thousand months what can we
do in this month a lot if we aim our aim
should be the last 10 nights every
single night let's try our best to read
more Quran because if you read more
Quran it's as if we've been reading
around for 83 years pray taraweeh sunnah
prayers stay all night in prayer if you
can because if you catch a little cuddle
it's as if you afraid 83 years 83 years
there's a lifetime opportunity also make
sure you give in charity and help those
that are needy and also don't forget to
the vicar of allah subhanaw taala simple
light on the tongue but heavy on the day
of judgement on the scales it's very
simple balance sister wherever you are
whatever you do at that night time
hamdulillah Subhan Allah start for Allah
la ilaha illallah these words
wallahi it's as if for 83 years you're
gonna be uttering them imagine what
Allah he our Lord is merciful he wants
us to go paradise and has given us all
these opportunities but which one of us
are going to grab onto them and in Shaun
McCutcheon Laila so covered and benefit
from that
don't miss it hope you guys enjoyed that
video don't forget to share subscribe in
life and join the down movement while
becoming at our movement member today by
clicking the link below